espagne plus de port du masque
obligatoire dans la rue à partir
d'aujourd'hui une décision du
gouvernement alors que la situation
sanitaire se stabilisent après la
sixième vague les précisions sur place
avec clémentine landes
on respire mieux en espagne depuis sept
semaines le gouvernement a levé le port
du masque obligatoire à l'extérieur
c'était une mesure qui était en vigueur
depuis la mi-décembre ici en fait depuis
le début de la sixième vague qui a été
la plus importante ici en espagne
aujourd'hui la situation sanitaire
semble se stabiliser les contaminations
sont moins nombreuses et le taux
d'incidence est en baisse
on compte 1997 cas pour 100000 habitants
sur ces deux dernières semaines c'est
donc bien loin des plus de 3000 cas à la
mi janvier le risque reste donc
néanmoins élevés en espagne mais le
gouvernement s'en préoccupe beaucoup
moins depuis ces dernières semaines
notamment parce que la population est
largement vacciner en effet huit
espagnols sur dix en deux doses de
vaccin est presque un sur deux a reçu la
troisième
la situation a donc radicalement changé
pour les autorités et pour preuve le
match n'est plus obligatoire à
l'extérieur même quand la distanciation
social n'est pas respectée alors pour
beaucoup de barcelone et la mesure
n'était de toute façon pas forcément
efficace
notez n'dri yao blayac dans les relaxes
ça n'aurait pas dû être obligatoire à
l'extérieur c'est une bonne décision car
en plus ça permet de mieux respirer
parce que tout ça va avoir des
conséquences à force et encore plus sur
les enfants les pauvres moi je le porte
sous le menton et quand j'entre quelque
part je le mets je respecte mais je n'y
crois pas trop
c'est super bien de ne plus devoir
porter de masque dans la ruche depuis la
dernière fois où c'est redevenu
obligatoire cela me paraissait être une
mesure inappropriée parce que les
contaminations étaient plus élevés mais
la pandémie était beaucoup plus légère
et on avait le droit d'aller prendre un
verre en plein air avec beaucoup de
monde alors c'est est idiot de devoir
mettre le masque dans la rue d'ailleurs
moi ça fait plusieurs jours que je ne
mettais plus j'étais complètement contre
avec talent il faut surtout respecter
les distanciation sociale si je sors
avec des membres de ma famille pour ne
pas les contrarier je mets parfois le
masque mais de toute façon je les sur
moi prêt à le mettre dans tous les lieux
fermés ou alors s'il ya beaucoup de
monde et amour progresser c'est la
hausse
l'extérieur vous la distance n'est pas
respectée il faut pas oublier que
d'autres mesures sont aussi en vigueur
dans certaines régions d'espagne par
exemple des jeux d'occupation le
passeport sanitaires pour rentrer dans
certains établissements ou encore des
heures de fermeture imposée dans les
bars et les restaurants par exemple
l'espagnol au 10 donc adieu aux masques
dans la rue mais pas aux copies de 19